اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز اهلا بكم الاحتلال
يرتكب 13 مجزره في قطاع غزه خلال 24 ساعه
راح ضحيتها
112 شهيدا ومنظمه الصحه العالميه تقول ان
100 الف شخص تعرضوا للقتل او الاصابه في
الحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع واليونيسيف
تقول ان نحو 17 الف طفل فلسطيني في غزه فق
قدوا ذويهم او انفصلوا عن
عائلاتهم اشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال في المناطق الغربيه لمدينه غزه
وكتائب القسام تعلن استهداف دبابه وناقله
جند اسرائيليتين غربيه خان يونس وقنص ضابط
في تل الهواء وجلن يقول ان الجيش فكك قوه
حماس في خان يونس وان الخطوه التاليه هي
رفع وسط مظاهرات لعائلات الاسرى في تل
ابيب تزامنا مع اجتماعات حكوميه اسرائيليه
بشان صفقه التبادل واشنطن تؤكد ان مقترح
الصفقه المطروح قوي وبناء ونتنياهو يقول
ان الحرب ستتواصل حتى تحقيق النصر
والمتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه يقول ان
حماس تسلمت مقترح الهدنه في اجواء ايجابيه
وانهم في انتظار
ردها قوات الاحتلال تواصل حمله الاقتحامات
والدهم وتعتقل 25 فلسطينيا في الضفه
الغربيه وبايدن يقول ان عنف المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين يزعزع الاستقرار الاقليمي
ويفرض عقوبات على اربعه مستوطنين في حين
رات رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه ان
العقوبات الامريكيه غير مبرره وسموت ريتش
يدعو الى التصديق على خطه لبناء 7000 وح
حده استيطان جديده في الضفه الغربيه الى
اللقاء